[Music]
when the show first ended did you ever
think that this many years in the future
you would be back together on television
no never in a million years did I ever
think we'd be back again and there's
always rumors about our reunion and
there was always going to happen but it
never did so when it actually did I
didn't believe them find any sort of
love in Miami I mean I find love every
single day but I fall out every single
morning what about this mushroom the
duck phone like what do you write pay
homage to the most the duck bone is
actually like a cast member it's like
one of the family so yeah it's there
this mushrooms there it's all there I'm
not the only one that uses it I
definitely use it but this other people
that use it as well I'm trying to find
the right one to share my life your
daughters turning five yeah in October
yes how do you feel like fatherhood has
changed you um you know what now I'm
even more picky when I pick women to
actually meet her oh my mother like only
the certain ones will meet that that's
why I like I put my standards up higher
a lot higher now is dating hard having a
daughter well it's just hard in general
now cuz you got to question their
motives and intentions it's hard dating
and generous why I'm single so you're
supposed to look first supposed to just
come so I'm hoping the happy are you
gonna be crazy protective of her oh yeah
I'm super protective she can date you
know she's 30 what moment are you a
little bit anxious for people to see
this season a lot of people think that
we might not have it anymore or it's not
gonna be drama it's not gonna be crazy
this is the craziest when we've ever
done so yeah I just want them to see it
that super teaser that came out I'm glad
they put that out because that shows how
it actually is where's Mike is now two
years sober yeah how have you as a
friend supported him through that
journey it was weird because I never
knew him to be sober and I didn't want
to drink around him so at first I didn't
drink around him but then he was like
he's so cool with it like he's so good
and so he's like he's still party with
us but he just didn't drink so but we
supported him in that
[Music]